I've had the pleasure of getting to talk
to him and work with him at a time or
two was Alec Baldwin and I I just I know
that you live across the street from
Alec in New York he is such a
personality a larger-than-life
personality
what's it like living across the street
from Alec ball he's definitely the mayor
of the Central East Village you you know
there are people in the trade who you
know like to put on a baseball cap and
sunglasses and kind of move quietly Alec
is Alec is on the street shaking hands
currying votes for who knows what
yeah I don't know yeah but he is you
know
Alec joking aside you know that you know
the old the symbol of drama was the the
comedy mask in the tragedy mask and Alec
is obviously he's this incredibly gifted
comedic actor and satirical actor and
but people free I never forget he is
really one of the great dramatic actors
of his generation and desire on Broadway
and just owning it and I I wanted him in
that gear that Glengarry Glen Ross yes
they obvious for closers only opening of
Glengarry Glen Ross is where I think of
him always and I think there are very
few actors that have that kind of
ballast that can come out do a scene
like that like and and a lethal capacity
to intimidate in a way and he he brings
that gear in this film it's it is one of
his career best dramatic performances
and he is he is just jaw-droppingly
great in it but people and people have
been really slammed in the back of their
seat by this almost Shakespearean right
now it seemed like on the set - I would
imagine he commands a lot of attention
when he's on a set in a scene I would
think he's just he's not what he's
actors it quietly comes in does his
scene and then quietly slipping it out
we eat some yogurt you know no Alec Alec
holds a lot of space he holds a lot of
space he and he it's very interesting
he's like he's the he's the opposite of
a method actor he likes to sustain the
energy and if you know if you're he
doesn't like to cut hill hills but don't
you cut camera like he'll you know he'll
he'll
he will like it's a lot of fun to direct
you know like like he will sort of like
he'll do these things to pump himself up
between the takes he'll go you know boom
like you know and and yeah is he is he
saying boom and zip and Powell to
himself like right but he really does it
and he does you do feel it like the next
take you're like wow you know but he he
womanpower find zip you know we don't
get me your hand doesn't get me anywhere
here we go zip on the flip so he's he's
um he's he's tough and needy right
because he'll he'll say another time he
was giving a terrific speech and I kept
telling the extras who were off camera
you know be quiet be quiet like like we
need his sound clean on this speech and
he kind of was doing it and he stops and
goes can't they applaud now Edward
no he watch it yeah why what's it I will
not be denied he is he is a we're joking
cuz he's an animal of the trade he loves
the work but he's got an incredible
command of language and he's terrific
but he is great to everybody he is he is
in your corner he's kind to everybody I
loved working with him